they had a man speaking of alcohol in
head-butting they had a black man that
um that one time we go get like taka vu
keys to be the kind of vodka that we
would drink it was just like this
off-brand in our region like Todd's
almost uh yeah probably like something
like that just like whatever every place
had their own little local brand or
whatever this this was called taka and
so you go get a fifth attack or whatever
so one time I'll pull up by the gas
station and they had this man not
singing out this guy will buy some Bach
he looks like he drink some vodka and it
was daytime you know it's probably maybe
11 a.m. so uh I pick it I say hey man
will you get us some liquor he said yeah
said all right here's the money you got
to go in and get the liquor come back
out and get in the car it's kind of dude
yet to give exact directions to ya know
otherwise getting deviate from the plan
I buy like some [ __ ] slim jims and a
scratch yes [ __ ] the dice yeah so
anyway he gets back in the car he's got
the liquor and that's when this dude
told me he's like you know I'm the head
button champion in the world right last
thing you want to hear from I'm talking
this guy the only man I've ever seen
yeah he had that thick head oh this
guy's head was probably made by that
shoemaker right he had that kind of head
he had a smaller than chin said chin has
a dome one it was like chin said with
another yeah it was that Jonas snowman
was like stacking up a couple of chins
heads right this guy had just like you
could see his knit you could hear his
neck if you put your ear up to his neck
he couldn't his neck oh man I'm tired
you know and he was head button people
know he goes I'm driving us off he has a
vodka and all my I want the vodka from
him right kind of you [ __ ] up and he
goes you know I'm the head button
champion of the world right in this news
home okay you say I don't know there's
cancer and this before they had it this
way before this is 20 years before Kimbo
Slice right yeah and this man look
exactly like Kimbo Slice right both
white with a two-story hit white or
black all right 100 percent black and he
so next thing you know you guys you know
him the hit button chambered in the
world and you start to see him kind of
just looking at me as
just feel like suddenly sizing up you
don't ya suddenly I'm looking forward
driving and he's looking directly at me
right feel there is no us we're not
going anywhere anymore he is just in the
car with me and uh and so I pull in he
goes do you want he goes do you think
you could beat me and I knew but when he
said do you think anything at that point
I'm already with the cops I'm thinking
oh my funeral
I'm thinking to buy back out but you
can't just get out of a car when you're
driving it and that's one of the issues
with cars is that you ever some
responsibility to stay in there at least
it's yours
so I stopped pull over because I'm not
gonna get knocked unconscious while I'm
moving forward you know what I'm saying
about a [ __ ] idiot yeah
so this dude he goes you want to know
and he couldn't even hear me anymore
that I'm saying no you see it read oh
yeah
for him it's gay yeah I'm saying no in
different ways and saying no in
different languages and you can tell
it's not registering in his head and he
just lines me up right and just hit me
as hard as he could with his [ __ ]
head yeah not me completely unconscious
I won't even knocked out twice in my
life once was actually about three weeks
ago when I fell in love the stuff when I
was wrestling with some children the
other time was when this dude the
self-proclaimed head button champion of
the world if I can put that one hit
sleeper on me bro here's the crazy part
he didn't touch with his hands
everything was gone dude everything was
going home with me
that's the chant though that's the chair
would you say hi to champ it's a kind of
an honor man my first thought was that
dude he's the champ and my first thought
that's the champ right there kid
bring up head-butting champ of the world
he's like be on there but I think it's a
real competition have you ever seen that
the slapping contest oh yeah we used to
do that put sugar in each other's mouths
and try to slap it out really yeah
this guy epic head-butting oh that guy
looks like a rapist honestly yeah a
little bit of the world all right let's
see it and I'm guessing
for JPEG right there oh you have the
solid forehead on oh yeah guys does
somebody down I don't want like this is
like something Joe put up sticker end us
this is like some [ __ ] Brian would do
but like literally training runs like ow
aah
my family's from Zimbabwe
I am very short because we used to eat
berries off the vine not a good
impersonation really
oh here's the guy headbutt an animal a
bichon hopefully is it a Bichon what's a
dude this video Hall looks absolutely
amazing this one it's a helmet on how's
it go oh you better get [ __ ] up I go
oh that's kind of [ __ ] up to do the go
Oh
goats [ __ ] them up oh this dam is in
Louisiana
oh they're auditioning for something
well [ __ ] just trying to make ridiculous
wrong winner gets to [ __ ] somebody at
the house I bet thing that's awesome
that what animal oh wow that's guy looks
pretty fun your mom so bout to get a
headache thank you mom thank you go back
to and go to the WorldStarHipHop
headbutt compilation right there and
this man oh yeah you know as good a
solid head but you [ __ ] your world took
me out god I wish it was really good
night though they didn't have video back
then there was a drawing of it I think I
told my buddy you need drew a picture of
it somebody but something I think you
should legalize head butts in the UFC
why did this is a fake video
oh they're illegal hell yeah they're
illegal this is the worst fighting worse
[ __ ] [ __ ] on their 3-handset person's
wearing it's not a WorldStarHipHop what
pants would you fight in if you had to
fight dude in pants yeah oh really
do you like these he's a little stretchy
but they cover everything I need to
cover but they're not too bad either
you know there's time if I can work if
you were in a yeah and they're tight in
the ankle you know that's what I want I
was ready for that yeah yeah I'm so
stupid this is so Russian yeah this is
some Russian [ __ ] the slapping
competition though I think how people
don't get most of them do they just get
knocked the [ __ ] out to tough for their
own good
you've been slapped really hard mmm I
think let me think what happened a girl
slapped with yeah slap you guys I feel
like it's more embarrassing than a punch
I really push on a slap there's dude
named Wade slapped me one time fat Wade
was very wide Wade slap you you know he
just didn't have much to say and he was
angry for years and it finally came out
in a big slap and his daddy drove the
school bus his dad was a Milford and his
dad drove the school bus and he was
Irish
I guess who was Irish I don't know he
never really said anything
Wade and Milford don't celebrate I read
that's true good point yeah so they
might not have been Irish dude but they
looked really Irish had a lot of Irish
characteristics for not being from there
and they are a meal for drove the bus
dude short bus regular dude well and I
never wrote short actually one time I
rode short but just to talk to the
driver was hot as [ __ ] dude dude we had
the finest short bus driver and I
pretended you were kind of slow just to
get on the short bus oh dude I get on
there
one of my buddies right he thought he
was trying to be handicapped on there he
tied his legs together right and made
like a long like Forrest Gump stuff yeah
and he tried to pretend he had one leg
like dude that's how you've written you
up one leg like you tie one leg behind
you or something just like you had two
legs tied together he probably works
issues like this dumb ass yeah go and
get on the bus get in the back she's
probably like I bet this boy's got a
dick on him you know cuz I would think
that if I saw somebody with one big-ass
thick leg boy you have a fat dick to the
front they have to be they say that
people that are 511 have big dicks
that's what I've heard some girl told me
that life
eleven she just said if you're 511 or
shorter or like five nine to five eleven
you have like a fat dick syndrome fat
and short yeah like you ever seeing that
that documentary on HBO it's called like
night women or something like that's on
prostitutes and they Mike this one
prostitute up it's my favorite scene
ever in the documentary because they
might grow up and she gets in a car with
a John and he she goes i baby get it out
and they're like negotiating the price
she was right baby get out and they just
hear your silence and then hear slurping
there here you go ooh you got that you
got that short fat that short fat date
my favorite scene everybody that dude to
moon now why Dixie heater man I came in
wide broad when I was young and I
remember it takes almost all the blood
out of your body you can't think that
well when you get an erection I got like
like one of those short coke cans you
know that you give the kids on a short
one short and fat is yours a full coke
can now or yeah I mean I got it I mean
it's yeah but I'm more like I'm
definitely more of a width and a length
guy you know what I'm saying like you
see my dick you like oh I put a watch on
that you know Oh weird but you don't see
it and be like oh you know that thing
can be a ruler yeah yeah I got that
young attack artist bro I got that
chubby in the [ __ ] you know I got
Napoleon's kind of taller chubby brother
but still no yet the job dig the chubby
my dick couldn't really wear a
turtleneck as it doesn't really have a
neck it's just all oh yeah basically the
cankles of dick a solid ankle the hand
bro it's almost it's like Jared Lorenz
in the used to play Ricki University
Kentucky quarterback lick of the tracks
that's like what season like oh we just
can't anymore
that [ __ ] for Kentucky had a
cannon have you seen him lately and
something low blow League there he is
got that right there yeah throwing a
waffle interest cousin's mouth right
there above [ __ ] is huge ain't good
slang that flip there is in college in
gay there he is right there in college
he was an animal you solid for sure but
yeah man that put that man put me
unconscious do you have on champ he was
a champ and I never saw him again and he
took that liquor and that was it
hopefully you know hopefully just
probably stop I've guarantees he's dead
for sure
this boy's close to dying - he's 500
pounds oh wow there is right there
trying to rip into a bag of chips with
that third pitcher on the right you know
what I assume he has a cankle dick as
well you know what's funny is that's
hilarious to me that he came to a show
one time and brought me a shirt when I
performed in Lexington oh really yeah
and it says straight out of Lexington on
it's pretty cool he's a nice guy yeah
super nice but yeah I mean he makes fun
of himself all the time I mean he's it
well this nobody was built like him play
quarterback ever yeah playing a left
tackle playing quarterback
yeah people I can't play marbles or play
Dungeons & Dragons right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]